why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so picking up with Civil War Frontline
Issue Number Eight what we see is that
where previously the involvement of
Norman Osborne and this whole Atlantean
incident uh seem to really kind of be uh
mysterious seem to really kind of be
these disheveled and fragmented pieces
of a puzzle we begin to see that this
puzzle really kind of begins to come
together and that we're slow piecing
together what's going on here what we
see is that Ben Yurick is meeting with a
friend of his named Dany and Dany is
part of the NYPD and he's part of the
costume division meaning that his job is
to essentially uh investigate crimes
that have taken place where unregistered
superheroes have been involved and then
report his findings to uh his superiors
who in turn May hand this information
over to shield and what we really kind
of see going on is that of course he's
more or less kind of tip Ben URI off and
is kind of taking Ben along the crime
scene that's being investigated where we
had previously seen the death of
multiple atlanteans and the injuries
that were sustained by Wonderman and
what we see going on here is that uh
Danny's really talking to benuck about
how things just don't add up some things
just don't make sense that for right now
the story is being issued as a warehouse
fire but Danny says that there's no way
that this is a warehouse fire that it's
definitely not the case and that Shield
or I'm sorry that NYPD for the most part
really has no idea what it was uh for
the most part Shield is kind of involved
here in the sense that they're trying to
get jurisdiction over this area but
because of the fact that it happened in
New York and because this is under the
jurisdiction of the NYPD it's really
kind of a a power struggle The Shield is
really kind of going to the district
attorney's office to attempt to uh gain
jurisdiction over this area but for the
time being it belongs to the NYPD what
we also see is that the two of them are
talking Ben you're asked Danny to kind
of take him through what's going on here
to really kind of take him through
what's being seen and Danny says that as
best they can tell it was some kind of a
terrorist cell but that all the people
that were killed here were verified to
be atlanteans and that the orange
markers that are placed throughout this
area indicate weapons of an unknown
nature but that they had passed the
information off to one of their weapon
analysis people and they had determined
that these were um Atlantean weapons of
some kind although they don't really
know who it is that really kind of set
set this up and they're not exactly sure
why they were here in the first place in
addition the question that Ben Yurick
asks is who would have the desire and
the resources to pull off something like
this who would go out of their way to
attack effectively what amounts to a
delegation of atlanteans with ambiguous
motives and then try to cover it up as a
warehouse fire and then we see that
Danny says that he's heard a rumor now
venu is a little frustrated here he's
really kind of asking Danny to spill the
beans but Danny says that he said a
little bit too much and and then the two
of them kind of engage in a cat and
mouse game of sorts where Danny says
that he can give Ben the information but
Ben wants to know or Danny wants to know
what Ben has to offer in return but Ben
really just kind of says give me the
information and Danny acquiesces Danny
says that according to his contacts
Vanessa a woman that we don't know who
was a dispatcher the night that the
event happened heard multiple
Transmissions over the radios from
shield and that the indication or the
information that's been gained is that
this individual that caused all this
pandemonium was the Green Goblin and Ben
yuck again asked this question why would
Norman Osborne do this why would Norman
Osborne go out of his way and attack
atlantans it really just didn't make any
sense Danny indicates that he really
kind of has a I guess a more juicy bit
of information that will really kind of
answer this question but says that this
time he really wants something in return
from here we kind of switch over to
Sally Floyd and we learn that in order
for Ben Yu to gain the information that
Dany had that Ben Yurick set up Sally on
a blind date with Dany but Sally's a
little uh skeptical about this she's not
necessarily upset and Ben really kind of
tells her that Danny's a really cool guy
and that she'll enjoy the experience and
so she agrees and hangs up the phone
from here we pick up with Sally Floyd
and what we see is that Sally Floyd is
meeting with some unsavory individuals
but for the most part they really kind
of exist as contacts for her whenever
she's trying to gain information on
what's going on as far as some
underground activities and and is able
to kind of get an upper hand on
authorities because she's able to gain
information they would just not normally
be able to gain themselves she's meeting
with two individuals named Jerry and
Doug and as the two of them are kind of
progressing they're really kind of
getting caught up on each other they're
really kind of getting caught up on
what's been going on and of course she
really has some uh I guess some
light-hearted flirtatious conversation
with both Jerry and Doug and then we see
that she's introduced to a man named
Stevie and Stevie is really kind of a a
disheveled a sort of homeless guy that
we really don't know anything about but
of course Doug really kind of vouches
for him and says that he's known Stevie
for several years and that Stevie has
some information that Sally Floyd may
find interesting Sally Floyd of course
asks Stevie about it and Stevie says
that he was out by the docks and he saw
a few individuals throw a body into the
river and then heard some sort of hushed
conversation between the two of them and
they had mentioned things like an
interaction between Sally Floyd and
supposedly a man named Nick Fury now
this really kind of of course catches
the attention of Sally Floyd because to
her knowledge Nick Fury is missing no
one really knows where he is and so it
really kind of catch her by surprise or
really kind of be interesting if Nick
Fury had somehow gone out of her way or
gone out of his way to speak directly
with Sally Floyd and to kind of give her
an indication that of course she's being
followed and that there is uh not
necessarily as much to this story as she
believes is actually going on we of
course see that Stevie agrees to take
her to the location where he heard these
conversations and and saw the body being
thrown in the water but says he will
only do it if she is willing to give him
$50 and pay for the wings that he's just
eaten we see that she of course asked
Doug whether or not this is something
that's worth going through and Doug says
again that he can vouch for Stevie that
he's known Stevie for a few years and
that he's a trustworthy source so Sally
says that she'll agree only under the
condition that it's $30 and she'll pay
for the wings we see that uh we switch
back to Ben Yurick and Dany and as the
two of them are kind of talking of
course Danny's asking asking questions
about Sally Floyd he's really kind of
interested in the woman that he's
presumably going to go on a on a blind
date with and then we switch back to the
uh the more pressing topic which is the
information that Dany has regarding the
involvement of Norman Osborne and why it
is that he would have attacked
atlanteans Danny asked Ben urick if he
ever plays the stock market or if he is
aware of how to play the stock market
and Ben uich says he is to a degree but
he's really not the kind of individual
that would invest his money and really
kind of play with it so frivolously
Danny says that one of his shield Le
aison says there's more going on with
this Green Goblin thing than meets the
eye and the way that he had heard it
there was a major problem as far as the
inside situation involving Reed Richards
and Iron Man and the whole Shield issue
and the reason is that of course they
had released these super villains and uh
had implanted in them Nanobots and these
Nanobots would be way for them to
regulate their behavior and that that
was supposed to be the way that it was
happening with the Green Goblin but for
some reason he's gone awall and we see
that Ben Yurick of course says this
couldn't have happened by accident and
Danny replies that's what their liaison
thought and so they did some digging
around and did some poking around and
this liaison um I guess reported to Dany
that someone had betrayed them from
within that someone set Norman Osborne
free on purpose and then we see that uh
Danny's really kind of pointing to the
idea that the whole basis of this is
that somebody is capitalizing on this
somebody's making money on this and the
question was who was the one that's
manufacturing these Nanobots who was the
one that is producing this stuff in
order for the government to use it as a
means of controlling uh super villains
so that they can play out the role of
capturing various superheroes and he
says the person that uh is is the one
supplying this kind of technology is of
course Tony Stark and Ben York's really
kind of surprised by this Ben York's a
little skeptical about this and Ben York
says that that doesn't make a whole lot
of sense that it wouldn't it wouldn't
make much sense for for Tony Stark to
take the Green Goblin out of uh
imprisonment to give him Nanobots only
to turn around and reprogram the
Nanobots so that um the Green Goblin
could effectively go on a killing spree
killing atlantans and then turn around
and deny involvement and to act as if
nothing makes sense or he has no idea
what's going on and then Danny counters
this by saying that if for example the
actions of the Green Goblin led to a war
between the United States and the
atlanteans
who were the people that would benefit
from this and that it would be the arms
manufacturers and then he asked the
question what if the entire Civil War
incident was all about money from here
we switch back to Sally Floyd and we see
that Sally Floyd is again following
Stevie and stev's really kind of just
talking to her some light-hearted
conversation nothing too major but of
course he says that um he had promised
Doug that he would keep an eye on Sally
Floyd make sure that she stayed safe as
they were moving through the uh through
the ports and then of course they arrive
at the warehouse where or I guess the uh
the shack where Stevie says that he had
heard some whispered discussions and so
on and what we see here is that as the
two of them are beginning to enter the
shack that Sally Floyd realizes that
there's really no one here and she
thinks that maybe it's some kind of a
setup maybe it's some kind of a trap but
then once she opens the door she sees
that Captain America's shield is there
and it's revealed that Stevie is in fact
Steve Rogers from here we switch over to
the story of speedball to Robbie Baldwin
and what we see is of course that uh
Maria Hill is really kind of
investigating and really kind of
pressing and interrogating She-Hulk and
the reason for this is because the
circumstances involving Robbie Baldwin's
presumable attempted Escape despite the
fact that he didn't make it that far
away and was found unconscious uh is
questionable because it's left She-Hulk
injured and there are very few things
that could actually injure She-Hulk and
even Jennifer Walters himself is herself
is a little confused about the situation
is really kind of unsure about what's
going on of course at the moment she's
been temporarily blinded and she talks
to Maria Hill about how there are very
few things that could actually blind her
there are very few things that could
actually injure her and she herself is
really kind of uh scared and confused
and that if there was anything she had
to offer any kind of information that
would effectively um help Maria hill
come to a conclusion as to what's going
on she would of course hand that
information over from here we switched
to the perspective of Jennifer Walters
during the presumable incident that took
place in the uh ambulance and she was
talking about how Robbie Baldwin was
jumping in and out of Consciousness how
he kept calling for his mother and he
wasn't really sure what was going on and
Jennifer Walters maybe thought that he
was suffering from some state of
psychosis or some sort of mental
breakdown and that there were a series
of electrical charges there was some
kind of electrical buildup and that it
came from everywhere inside the
ambulance and that Jennifer Walter's
inherent ability when she can transform
into the into She-Hulk that it gives her
enhanced abilities one of which is being
able to observe the blinding flash of
light of a nuclear explosion from 2
miles away but whatever it was that
happened inside that ambulance was so
bright that it actually caused her to
temporarily go blind and that she thinks
that what had happened is that some of
her power had been siphoned away that
some of her energy had been taken away
from her and that nothing like that had
ever happened Maria Hill is immediately
skeptical about this she believes that
maybe somebody possibly with the
involvement of She-Hulk had attempted to
uh help Robbie Baldwin escape from
custody She-Hulk of course says this is
preposterous and that if this is the
argument that Maria Hill is making Maria
Hill has no real justification for
holding her here but Maria Hill says
that because this situation is more or
less uh perceived to be an attempted
escape attempt at the hands of somebody
else helping Robbie Baldwin that she can
in fact hold uh Jennifer Walters for a
prolonged amount of time for 3 days what
we also see is is that uh Maria Hill is
meeting with her assistant and her
assistant tells her that there's a
little more bad news in addition to
what's happened so far that there's
going to be a congressional hearing
involving the issue regarding Bal Robbie
Baldwin being shot and that Congress is
really kind of looking at the idea that
perhaps Shield had really kind of
allowed security to be more La they had
taken away the normal amount of security
that had been there in the hopes that
someone would shoot Robbie Baldwin and
that he would in fact die in addition we
learned that Robbie Baldwin's older
cellmate a cellmate that he had had
before he was transferred to uh to the
negative Zone was a man named hickey and
that this this individual had escaped
his prison cell no one knows where he is
but what we actually see is that he's
the custodian in the hallway cleaning
where Maria Hill and her assistant are
talking from here Maria Hill transitions
over to a conversation with Reed
Richards and we see that Reed Richards
is for the most part examining Robbie
Baldwin and she asks what's going on if
they if he has any kind of hypothesis
any kind of information on what it was
that happened with Robbie Baldwin inside
the ambulance and Reed Richard says for
the most part he has no real idea that
to the best of his knowledge that maybe
there's some kind of instance going on
where dormant mutant powers are awake or
dormant superpowers are Awakening inside
of him where for whatever reason he is
now uh more powerful than he was before
but they don't know exactly how it works
they don't know exactly what the effects
will be if he'll be more powerful now
than he was before from here we
transition over to the story or or back
to the story of uh of Joe the Atlantean
and what we really kind of see going on
here are a few things the first thing is
of course that we see a kind of TV
advertisement of sorts where they're
talking about uh some of the combative
actions that have been taking place
about the Civil War kind of being fought
on the streets of various cities and
some of the injuries that have gone on
they talk about um Wonderman who of
course is still recovering from his
injuries as a result of the attack at
the uh the warehouse house on the docks
and of course the news media is
reporting this as a warehouse fire as
it's been reported to them by the
authorities but then what we also learn
is that there is a delegation of
atlantans that are going to be uh
speaking publicly on the surface and
this is a very rare thing in fact I
don't think this has ever happened
before and the entire event is really
kind of being hosted by the superhumans
of Europe shei and these individuals are
really kind of providing them a place to
air their grievances because what we
really kind of see going on is that
Atlantis or the atlantans are really
looking to at the very least recover the
bodies of those individuals who were
killed in the warehouse but before any
of the Grievances can actually be aired
before the atlantans can really kind of
uh get too far into their discussions we
see that Norman Osborne shoots the head
of the Atlantean delegation and then we
see that Norman Osborne is apprehended
from here the atlantian delegation
Retreats back into the ocean and one of
the members of the the uh superhero
group superhumans of Europe of course
tries to plead with the atlantans
telling them that it wasn't their
intention this was a mistake and of
course we see that Norman Osborne is
really kind of panicking here and really
kind of sputtering and says that he
didn't do it that he swears it wasn't
his
[Music]
fault so as the Civil War event begins
to wind down to a close we pick up with
Civil War Frontline Issue Number Nine
and what we see here is that Sally Floyd
is being granted an interview by Captain
America and this is not something that
we've seen yet since the very beginning
of Civil War since Captain America was
able to overpower The Shield forces led
by Maria Hill and go underground we have
not seen an instance where Captain
America has really kind of publicly
spoken out about his stance regarding
the Civil War registration or his
position as the leader of the
underground movement and what we see
here is that as the inter interview kind
of progresses that Sally Floyd is very
disheartened by what she's hearing
because what she's hearing is really
kind of the opposite of what you would
expect to hear from Captain America and
what I would like you guys to do is pay
very close attention to the things that
he is saying because these will come I
guess these will become particularly
important as we get to the end of Civil
War and the final confrontation between
the forces of Captain America and the
forces of Tony Stark and so what we see
here is that Sally Floyd begins by
asking him what it is that he's trying
to convey what it is that he's trying to
say and what it was that happened that
caused him to turn against Shield we see
that Captain America replies by saying
that he didn't turn against Shield that
he asked for time to review this policy
to review the uh superhuman registration
act before it went into implementation
but that they didn't give him time to
that cooler heads really kind of needed
to Prevail here that people really kind
of needed to take some time to really
kind of calm down after the events of St
Connecticut and not rush into a uh a
kind of fool hearty move and he really
kind of makes the argument that this is
no longer the country that he vowed to
defend that the United States is kind of
becoming this uh split down the middle
Territory between red and blue and that
it's really kind of more of the divided
States of America instead of the United
States of America and Sally Floyd really
kind of replies to this by saying that
she had always thought the United States
had kind of been a split of red and blue
there were always people who had held
these absolute political allegiances and
that that was one of the things that
really kind of made the United States an
interesting talking point among other
people across the world and that if uh
some kind of situation arose whereby
Captain America deviated from his normal
standard of being Duty bound his normal
standard of defending the rule of law
that it could potentially result in a
civil war especially if other
individuals followed his lead and
Captain America replies by saying that
war is anything but civil and that it's
the last resort of the desperate and
that that's where we are right now he
talks about how for 60 years he had kind
of been looked to by the federal
government to be the uh I guess the
defender of freedom and this is really
kind of interesting here because Captain
America is really kind of presenting
himself as the last Bastion of freedom
in the United States at the moment that
he's really kind of the last righteous
individual and that everybody else is
really kind of leading the way towards
the World War II Nazi Germany kind of
society and he says that he sees what
happens when an insane idea gets out of
hand he talks about the kind of things
that he saw during World War II and how
Adolf Hitler was able to uh assuage the
minds of individuals towards an insane
cause and he was able to somehow rally
all these individuals towards
persecuting millions of individuals
under a single ideology and then we see
that it's just one bad idea he really
says that just one bad idea can really
cause things to spiral down into this uh
horrible place that nobody had really
envisioned anybody that the nation
itself actually going into Sally Floyd
is really kind of uh not necessarily
buying that she tells Captain America
that she really kind of wants to be
spared these comparisons between Nazi
Germany and that she's really not buying
into this kind of propaganda that he's
spilling she says that if he recalls
correctly that a lot of the German
soldiers who fought during World War II
were simply just soldiers following
orders and that the uh the Patriots they
were they were in effect Patriots
fighting for the wrong cause and Captain
America replies that's exactly his point
and he ask what it is that Miss Floyd is
really kind of trying to uh kind of
trying to establish he asked Sally Floyd
what it is that she's really kind of
trying to say and what she says is that
war the winner of war is not necessarily
anyone in particular that war is not
about who's right that war is about
who's left who it is that survives and
the surv survivors are the ones that
really kind of Define what the history
is going to be Captain America replies
that she's being a little simplistic but
she says that she really thought there
was going to be some kind of a story
here she really thought that maybe there
was going to be this idea of Captain
America having some sort of
philosophical belief or something more I
guess concrete than simply just
presenting himself as this sort of
freedom-based Messiah with this
perspective that everybody except for
him is wrong what we see is that Sally
initially had been given 15 minutes by
Captain America but she only chose to
take five and decides to leave to head
to her date with Danny what we see now
is we kind of switch over to Ben urick
and Peter Parker and the two of them
were really kind of
investigating the claims that had been
passed on to Dany from uh or passed on
to benuck by Dany that Tony Stark may
very well have had a hand and is really
kind of the uh the moving force behind
the Civil Civil War movement that he is
really kind of doing this for the
purpose of financial gain Peter Parker
and Ben Yurick have really kind of
installed a uh I guess a a worm of some
kind onto the uh accounting firm's
computers of Tony Stark and are
investigating the financial gains that
he's made over the years or kind of
investigating the uh money that he's
pulled in as a result of the actions
that have started since the beginning of
Civil War and what we see here is that
uh Peter Parker is is pointing out the
idea of money that that is really kind
of spiked up that while Tony Stark has
uh several subsidiaries that none of
these subsidiaries are generating money
out of the blue the company has somehow
come into a lot of money that the money
that the company has made has really
kind of I guess skyrocketed about two
days before Civil War but they don't
really know where it's coming from
there's really no Trail here there's no
finger they can point to and say this
money is coming from somewhere else
again Ben yuck is a little hesitant to
believe that Tony Stark is really kind
of manipulating the entire Civil War
event for the purposes of gaining money
and goes as far as to say this to uh to
Peter Parker to say that he doesn't
think that Tony Stark would manipulate
the lives of individuals for personal
financial gain and Peter Parker says
that he used to believe this until Tony
Stark started messing with his life from
here we transition over to the Avengers
Tower and what we see is that Reed
Richards and radioactive man are
investigating the Nanobots in the
bloodstream of Norman Osborne and they
see that these Nanobots have been
reprogrammed that something is entirely
different the question is raised by
radioactive man if it's possible that
his own body chemistry that Norman
Osborne's own body chemistry had altered
the programming of the Nanobots that
were put inside his body and Reed
Richards says no this isn't the case
that somebody has actually given him uh
something to either suppress these
Nanobots or to reprogram these Nanobots
but that it had to have been somebody
from within and Reed Richards tells uh
tells radioactive man that he needs to
investigate what's going on here he
needs to look into what's happening
because Miss Marvel arrives and informs
them that they've picked up movement off
the Atlantic coast from Virginia down to
Florida and it appears as though the
atlantans are really uh I guess making
preparations to wage war against the
United States although nothing's really
happened yet and what we see is that
with radioactive men having been tasked
by Reed Richards to investigate this
issue of the Nano probes that no one is
above investigation that radioactive man
is to investigate everybody which
includes Tony Stark Reed Richards Hank
Pim anybody who could have had access to
these Nano probes what we also see is
that Tony Stark pulls Reed Richards
aside and ask to speak to with him
privately and Reed Richards is of course
a little hesitant due to the fact that
there's so much going on at the moment
but of course he grants Tony Stark the
time to speak uh Reed Richards really
kind of talks about how what's going
going on here the attack of the Green
Goblin on the atlanteans has really come
at such a terrible time because the
attack on the atlanteans could be
considered by the atlanteans an act of
war and if they choose to go to war with
the United States at such a fractured
point when the superhero Community is so
divided that it could lead to a total
disaster and could very well result in
the total Destruction of the United
States as there would really be no
superheroes who could band together and
to fight off the atlantans but then we
see that uh Reed Richards of course
talks to uh Tony Stark and tells him
that he's considering going and seeing
um uh neyar the uh the Submariner
personally to really kind of investigate
what it was that was going on and then
of course we see Tony Stark telling Reed
Richards that he knows who the traitor
is and that he's known since the
beginning from here we switch to the
raft which of course is the prison where
individuals with superpowers are being
housed and we see that of course Rob
Baldwin is being held back in captivity
again from here we see that there
appears to be some kind of prison break
that is being organized by Razer fists
and other individuals and that the
prison break involves using Robbie
Baldwin as a human shield what we see is
that while some of the taunting is
taking place while some of the
individuals are really giving Robbie
baldwi a hard time that razor fist
physically grabs Robbie Baldwin and
appears to hold him hostage what we also
see is that Diamond Head has grabbed the
two guards that were escorting Robie
Baldwin as Razer fist was holding him
hostage as a means of a diversion and
kills both of the guards we then see
that Crimson Dynamo Justin Justine
Hammer is able to infiltrate the offices
of the guards that are monitoring this
situation and incapacitate the both of
them and orchestrate the release of all
the prisoners within the raft we then
see that the prison break commences the
exact way that you think it would where
the prisoners are sort of running around
and everybody's acting kind of in a
crazy pandemonium way but ultimately as
Razer fist is taking Robbie Baldwin that
he injures him and Robbie Baldwin
complains of course that uh that that
Razer fist had injured him and Razer
fist asks do you think that I care and
Robbie Baldwin says no that he likes it
and then we see a sudden explosion
within the raft and from there everybody
who was involved in the riot is
completely incapacitated Shield guards
arrive on the scene and are able to
apprehend Justine Hammer as well as the
other individuals who are now
unconscious and we see that Robbie
Baldwin is sitting within his cell and
says he's been thinking a lot about the
registration act and that he's come to a
decision and that he wants to know where
to
sign
he